okay thank you all very much for joining
us today my name is Bernie Sanders I am
chairman of the progressive Congress and
congressman from the state of Vermont
let us be frank and honest with the
American people the contract with
america is a fraudulent series of
proposals which will make the wealthiest
people in america wealthier while
causing intense pain and suffering for
the weakest and the most vulnerable
people in our country at a time when the
richest people are becoming richer when
the middle class is shrinking when
poverty is growing the contract with
america will provide huge tax breaks for
millionaires while cutting back on
programs that feed hungry children such
as food stamps the WIC program and the
school lunch program the rich get richer
in the united states a nation which has
seen a fifty percent increase in
childhood poverty in the last twenty
years in a nation which has the highest
rate of childhood poverty in the
industrialized world we'll see more of
its children in hunger what courage what
wisdom what family values what a
contract with america 25% of the elderly
people in this country live at lenia the
poverty level many despite medicare
cannot afford the prescription drugs
they desperately need or forced to
impoverish themselves for long-term care
when they apply for medicaid many
millions of other Americans have paid
into the Social Security system
throughout their entire working lives
and expect the right to fully draw upon
their benefits when they retire the
contract with america goes to war
against america's seniors the balanced
budget amendment will without a shadow
of a doubt begin the process of leading
to the destruction of the Social
Security system as we know
with or without that constitutional
amendment the contract with america will
slash medicare will slash Medicaid and
nutritional programs for the elderly at
a time when the Cold War is over when
the United States is spending many many
times more than any other nation on
earth for its military when russia wants
to join in nato when china has received
mfn status and has received billions of
dollars of vestments from american
corporations the contract with america
if you can believe it proposes to
significantly increase military spending
in march of 94 the House Republicans
proposed a 60 billion dollar increase in
military spending over a five-year
period meanwhile many thousands of
veterans will see their programs and
their needs cut and tens and tens of
thousands of middle-class young people
who want the opportunity to go to
college will not be able to enjoy that
opportunity because federal aid to
higher education and loans and grants
will be cut back as members of the
Progressive Caucus our task in the
coming hundred days is not only to
articulate what is wrong with the
contract of America and we absolutely
believe that the more the American
people know what is in that contract the
more opposition there will be but it's
not only to articulate and criticize
what's wrong with it we must bring
forward a different set of alternatives
point by point we acknowledge there are
serious problems in America but the
contract with america are not solutions
that benefit almost anybody other than
the very wealthy for example many of us
are concerned about by two hundred
billion dollar deficit but we think you
don't destroy Social Security and cut
Medicare you look at the military you
look at the CIA budget and the
intelligence budget you look at
corporate welfare many of us believe
that we should reform our welfare system
but not by throwing low-income kids into
orphanages or low-income families out on
the street we think an absurd to talk
about welfare reform
without talking about job opportunities
in education many us believe in the
concept of a citizen responsive
legislature but we say how do you have a
citizen's responsive legislature without
campaign finance reform so the more not
millionaires do not continue to buy
seats in the United States Congress what
the Progressive Caucus promises the
American people today is that we will do
all that we can in committees on the
floor of the house and in our
communities to expose the contract with
america for what it is and then to fight
for sensible alternatives ultimately the
final decision will be made by the
american people if you are concerned
about the contract with america and its
implications for the most vulnerable
people in our society then tell it to
the President and tell it to the members
that represent you ah thank you let me
now introduce major Owens a congressman
from New York City I think this caucus
has made it clear that the programs to
create jobs are our number one concern
and every step and this 104th Congress
we're going to move in ways to emphasize
the fact that we care about jobs we've
heard the voice of the majority of
Americans they made it quite clear and
the exit polls on Election Day in
numerous studies and the polls that
people are concerned about their jobs
those who have jobs of great anxieties
about keeping those jobs other people
feel they're underpaid and there's a
vast number of people we know who are
unemployed so at every step in the way
including this first 100 days we are
going to take steps to emphasize the
fact that the voice of the American
people are not being voices are not
being heard on the issue of jobs on the
balanced budget amendment for example we
intend to offer an amendment which we
call our fiscal Fairness Act which
merely states that employment job
creation investment in jobs as we
propose at our investment jobs at
investment of jobs are equal to national
security equal to threats to national
security at war they have a provision
which says Congress may waive the
provisions of this article meaning the
provisions of
balanced budget amendment for any fiscal
year and with your declaration of war is
in effect I if there's a national threat
to national security in the same section
we would like to add the provisions of
this article may be waived for any
fiscal year for which the president
notifies the Congress at the national
unemployment rate is a projected to
exceed four percent in case you don't
remember there is a law defect called a
full employment act the humphrey-hawkins
Act which says it four percent is the
level of unemployment at which you you
you you don't go to go above you we are
into a state of full employment we say I
will accept the unemployment when it's
four percent or less Alan greens
Greenspan is recently on his own decided
to make his own laws so he said it at a
higher level and and if unemployment is
it seven percent uh he will declare that
you have to take steps to cut off job
creation set of activities so that
inflation will not result we are looking
at the need to create jobs we think
that's as important as any activity of
our government managing the economy
guaranteeing that people have a way to
earn income that's as important as any
activity government and a balanced
budget amendment should not preclude the
government the Congress and the
president from taking the necessary
steps whenever necessary to create those
jobs and maintain a high level of
employment we of course have a bill
which we'll talk about later which will
create those jobs and we feel that
that's as important as any other
activity on the agenda more important
than providing a 40 billion dollars to
Mexico to bail out the the Wall Street
investors there we don't want to go into
a second Savings and Loan swindle
situation we had won the last ten years
and now 14 billion dollar bailout from
Mexico would be another savings and
loans kind of swindle of the American
taxpayers we think that that kind of
money ought to be used to create jobs
instead thank you lynn woolsey is a
congresswoman from California I
represent Moran and sonoma counties in
California and we've heard a lot about
how the Republicans have used
sophisticated polls to come up with the
content of their contract with america
what they forgot to do is to talk to
people who have real life experiences
with systems that they want and need to
change that kind of contribution is
crucial to good and workable public
policy and that's why am I am
particularly proud to have worked
closely with the Progressive Caucus on
our alternative to the Republican agenda
particularly our proposal on welfare
reform you see I know firsthand the
faults and merits of the welfare system
27 years ago I was a single working
mother who relied on welfare even though
I was employed I did that so that I
could give my three children there was
one three and five years old the health
care and the child care that they need
it that experience never leaves me and
it serves as the foundation for the
welfare reform proposal that we the
Progressive Caucus offer the American
public today make no mistake we know the
welfare system is broken it doesn't work
for recipients and it doesn't work for
taxpayers the question is how do we make
the system work to get families off
welfare for good the contract on America
would get families off welfare by
gutting the system leaving millions of
children without support and on the
streets the progressive solution on the
other hand would invest in our children
we do this by investing in insisting
that job training programs prepare
recipients for jobs that pay livable
wage and provide benefits we support
working poor families by providing them
with childcare health care and the end
and increased minimum wage so that they
do not need to turn to welfare in the
first place finally we revolutionize
child support collection by federalizing
our ineffective state-by-state system in
order to collect the 5.1 billion dollars
in child support that goes unpaid each
year I beg the Congress and so does the
Progressive Caucus not to use poor
children in our country escape goats
but rather to invest in their future so
they can lead strong productive lives
thank you thank you Jim McDermott is
congressman for the state of Washington
Jim thank you it just came from the Ways
and Means Committee and although I came
to talk about health care I can't help
but observe that the ways Means
Committee is at this moment considering
an adoption credit for families of five
thousand dollars on the one hand they
want to cut off welfare for women under
18 who have kids and on the other hand
they want to give five thousand dollars
for people to adopt now their belief is
that by cutting off those kids they'll
stop abortions and they'll all be
adopted that's what's going on in this
contract on America but even more
importantly is what's happening in the
fine print on health care in this
country even though the Republican
contract does not talk about any kind of
health care proposal it has a lot in
store for our health care in this
country here are the some of the things
that you haven't heard the Republicans
talk about when they sign that contract
or when they were on the campaign trail
responsible estimates indicate that in
order for the contract to be financed it
would require cuts of between 300 and
500 billion that's billion with abbie
dollars from Medicare and Medicaid now
what does that mean to the American
people I mean up close and personal it
means that private insurance rates will
skyrocket as providers try to make up
for lost revenues from privately insured
patients it means that Medicare
beneficiaries that's our parents and our
grandparents will have to pay much more
out of pocket for the health care or
lose access to health care at all it
means that some families are going to
have to start paying for their parents
and grandparents medical bills in
addition to their own or see their
parents do without you know young
families have enough to worry about
without having to worry about their
grandparents or their parents for 30
years they've had security in this
country that they didn't have to worry
about grandmas bills but they've even
forgotten
how that's put together the Republicans
in this process are going to remind
everybody because they're going to put
those medical expenses back on the
families I guess they think that young
people don't have enough to worry about
raising their own family now the cuts
necessary to finance the contract will
disrupt the entire healthcare delivery
system in this country for example
Children's Hospital's anybody who has a
Children's Hospital in their city should
go and figure out where the revenue
comes from in mine in Seattle forty
percent of children's orthopedic
hospital comes from Medicaid and if you
jerk forty percent out of the funding of
that Children's Hospital it will be on
its back some hospitals in this country
rely up to seventy percent on Medicaid
now we all care about deficit reduction
there than anybody up here who doesn't
care about that I don't want it on my
kids and none of these people wanted on
their kids or their grandchildren in
fact unlike the proponents of the
contract we all voted everybody in this
press conference voted for a plan to
reduce the deficit in the last Congress
we are not the party of big government
we are the party of a government that
believes the government should work for
the people that's why we support
single-payer health care reform no other
proposal offers as much for reducing the
deficit over the contracts proposed
lifespan but we do so by providing
affordable health care to every American
and guarantee their right to see their
own provider the provider that they
choose now the Republicans care about
long-term deficit reduction and about
the if they did and about the American
people they would support single-payer
health care reform there will be no
comprehensive reform out of these people
because they do not accept the principle
that everybody in this country is
entitled to have health insurance
single-payer health care reform
guarantees every American the security
of guaranteed health insurance and does
it without disrupting the present system
the American people are entitled to know
the truth about this contract on America
and this caucus is going to make sure
they learn it in the period that comes
thank you nydia velazquez as a
congresswoman